now the political tensions over the war
in Syria are reaching new heights this
weekend with the g7 countries including
the United Kingdom and the United States
facing off against Russia the Foreign
Secretary Boris Johnson has cancelled
his trip to Moscow today so where is
this all heading well I'm joined in the
studio now by the co-chair of the
parliamentary group Friends of Syria
Andrew Mitchell thanks very much for
wanting us on the program today
now the Defense Secretary has said that
Russia is guilty by proxy for some of
the all of the deaths that we saw in
this devastating chemical attack in
Syria earlier this week is he right yes
he is and the attack the appalling
attack which we saw could not have taken
place without either the active support
or the passive acquiescence of Russia
you've been a very fierce critic of
Russia's role in Syria in the past we
can have a look actually at something
you said about Russians actions in Syria
last year you said we are witnessing
events that match the behavior of the
Nazi regime in Guernica in Spain so do
you stand by that that Russia is acting
in a way similar to the Nazis absolutely
in the same way that the Italians and
the Germans destroyed the League of
Nations in the 1930s Russia has
completely undermined international
humanitarian law after all the Chemical
Weapons Convention which I think took
place in the 1920s survived the whole of
the Second World War no one used
chemical weapons and now we have
chemical weapons being used absolutely
appalling because of course the Russians
told the international community that
those weapons were being dismantled and
removed and here they are available to
Syrian forces in Syria today so where's
borz altan right to cancel his planned
trip to Moscow or is it better for him
to be there look them in the eye and
actually tell them face to face about
what they should be doing well I think
you know Boris Johnson makes his plans
and he's in a much better position to
judge whether he should be in Moscow
today than than I am but the fact is
that the international community has
been outraged by the behavior of Russia
and the Syrian government regime over
the last five years and thank goodness
the appalling error of judgment that was
made by President Obama in saying that
there were red lines which could not be
crossed and then doing nothing when
those
lines were cross which sent a signal to
Assad and to Russia that they could do
what they want thank goodness the
President Trump you know I wouldn't have
voted for him had I been an American at
the last election but thank goodness he
has reasserted the importance of
international humanitarian law he said
that he will not stand for war crimes
being committed and has acted in the way
that he did so you're praising Donald
Trump for that decisive airstrike on the
other hand we have reports out today
that Boris Johnson is going to be trying
to get a strongly-worded a hard-hitting
statement about Russia from the g7 so
while America is backing military action
we're trying to get a strongly worded
letter I mean is that enough well
America is the one country that could
take the action which was taken I think
that President Trump was decisive I
think he was proportionate and I think
he was absolutely right to do what he
did and all of us actually not just the
poor people in the cities in Syria but
all of us around the world can sleep
more safely as a result of international
humanitarian law being reasserted and
the world's main super pass standing up
for that which they weren't before
should the UK be prepared then to back
the US and literally well the UK should
be prepared as in an alliance with our
allies with America hopefully with the
UN as well though that is extremely
difficult because of the veto structure
that exists there hopefully the
international community will now say
that we simply cannot stand by and allow
international humanitarian law to be
broken but let's be clear what is
required in Syria today is a ceasefire
unfettered access for humanitarian
agencies a ceasefire that we were told
would be brokered and secured by Russia
Iran and Turkey and that's what we now
need to see and the critical thing is to
hold the Russians to their commitment on
the ceasefire that they will police it
and deliver it in every way they
possibly can and not as I say be
passively acquiescent in regime attacks
on innocent civilians the difficulty is
though isn't it that in the Syrian
conflict that doesn't really seem to be
a good side to back you have Assad on
the one hand who by all accounts is
carrying out these devastating chemical
attacks on his own citizens
there on the other hand you have own
opposition that is heavily in
treated by Islamic state if you attack a
sad are you just helping Islamic state
what we need is this ceasefire so that
negotiations can take place those
negotiations need to be from the bottom
up you're quite right that there are
fifty or so different parties in this
conflict in one way or another and it's
not for us to decide what a peaceful
outcome should be but what we can say is
that we will not stand by and allow
innocent civilians and children to be
murdered in the way they have been in
Aleppo and in many other places in Syria
as well in this conflict that's gone on
for many years thousands of people died
children we've seen chemical attacks and
we've seen the appalling of events in
some of these cities how much
responsibility does the UK and UK
politicians bear for suntanning buying
for not backing for example in 2013
military action well in my view that was
a terrible error of judgment by the
House of Commons and I think you know
svet hindsight is a great thing but
those of us who were passionately in
favor of Britain standing up then
against these abuses of international
humanitarian law I I think I think were
right we weren't able to carry the day
we weren't able to persuade our
colleagues of the importance of that and
I think when we look back we will say
that the international community has
been supine in the face of the most
extraordinary barbarity that's taken
place in Syria and done nothing about it
but again I think a lot of the blame for
that
was that an American president said that
he would take action if red lines were
crossed chemical weapons were there news
for the first time in a in the sort of
state way since the 1920s and he did
nothing about it at the same time though
taking action now when the picture is
more complex and perhaps it was in 2013
that risks confrontation with Russia
doesn't it I mean things could get very
very messy indeed well I think this is a
proportionate reaction to what happened
and I think it sends a very clear
message to the Kremlin that they cannot
break international humanitarian law and
that's extremely important it's not a
declaration of war against Russia were
standing up for international
humanitarian principles okay Andrew
Mitchell thank you very much for your
thoughts today